if you're like me most of your holiday
shopping is online these days am I right
hello I do go to shop still I support
big business small business I do it all
yeah but have you ever wondered about
the journey that the package goes on to
get to your doors yeah how does that
work right well that's why we are so
excited to be teaming up with Amazon
because they're delivering millions of
orders this holiday season and it's the
hundreds of thousands of employees at
its fulfillment centers delivery
stations and its drivers who make that
magic happen for all of us the customers
so and we get to watch the whole journey
unfold you wait till you see this I
recently got a chance to pull back the
curtain and see how it all goes down
take a look at this
I'm in Carteret New Jersey at an Amazon
fulfillment center this place is
humongous it's like multiple multiple
football fields so basically like the
same size of my house and I'm here with
Louise an actual Amazon employee hello
hi I'm so excited to be here today
welcome to Amazon I want to know the
Journey of a package how it all goes
down what's the first step well first
you got to order something all right I'm
gonna order
um Drew's cookbook Rubble Homemaker oh
that's a great choice okay and ordered
all right what's next let's go oh fun
after you hit by now the first step in
the process is the picking station the
picking station yeah that's a great name
for a single bar the picking station oh
I want to see this come on we have over
3 000 robots here wow yeah okay and so
they bring over shelves and it tells us
exactly where to find it so I ordered
Drew's book where where is that so if
you look on the screen here it says one
seat one see
there you go look I ordered it and here
it is okay and then we put it in the
tote right and then we push it in okay
but if I have a safe trip we have 14
miles of conveyor belts here really yeah
oh I miss it oh we'll see it too these
are our past stations this is where
everything gets put into the boxes
exactly oh look
look it made it what a journey this book
has been on so the next stage is we need
to pack it up this screen is going to
tell you exactly which one to use so
we'll grab that package over there same
to use an envelope like this okay great
okay and then you go in here yeah and
you can put it in and then
you scan the scan the barcode I know why
am I not good at putting a book in an
envelope all right where does this go
now right on the conveyor belt okay
see in a little bit
so this is the slam machine so slam
stands for scan label apply and manifest
so that means it's putting on labels on
the machine but before that the machine
actually scans each of those barcodes to
make sure that the package weighs the
amount it should can that machine scan
me and tell me how much I weigh right
now
don't worry I don't want I don't want
that I didn't sign up for that just get
that machine away from me where's it go
next it's going to go over to a delivery
truck
that's so much fun thank you for today
you're welcome thank you for coming oh
is this the truck that's bringing Drew's
book to the studio yes it is open I'm
gonna erase it and see if I can beat it
okay but thank you for today all right
bye come back anytime
for choosing my book it's me and pillar
of a homemaker of course it was such an
amazing experience and you you can also
appreciate just how many Amazon
employees and partners are key to
delivering the best experience for
Amazon customers every day and
especially during the holidays I know I
have a brand new appreciation for it
that was an incredible all the steps it
takes and here's the package here is the
package
I'm so excited because look in it is the
book here we go there you go I packed it
and it arrived here well
um you know I know that you wanted to
beat the delivery driver here but they
are so quick because they've already
come and gone oops but guess what what
they dropped off um some extra copies
that's right everyone in the audience is
going to go home with signed copies yeah
okay so happy holidays thank you Rossi
thank you Joe and thank you Amazon
[Music]
foreign